the senate will reconvene this morning
for closing arguments
in the impeachment trial of former
president trump trump's defense team
presented its case to senators yesterday
the final vote on his conviction or
acquittal could come as soon as this
afternoon
with at least one major question looming
will any witnesses be called to testify
at o'keefe is at the white house ed good
morning to you
good morning jeff the question of
whether they'll be witnesses remains an
open one and we won't know for certain
until the trial reconvenes later this
morning
but it's now moving at a pretty quick
clip the former president's attorney
spent less than three hours on friday
arguing
that the siege on the capitol was
pre-planned by others failing to mention
that he had spent months on twitter
complaining about the election results
and teasing a quote wild day on january
6th
clearly there was no insurrection
attorneys for former president trump
never once mentioned his unproven claims
about a stolen election
or tried to prove that he was robbed of
a victory instead they argued that mr
trump's language at a rally on the day
of the siege on the u.s capitol
was protected first amendment speech and
we fight
we fight like hell and that the
impeachment trial is the result of years
of relentless partisan attacks
it is constitutional cancel culture
this trial is about far more than
president trump
it is about silencing and banning the
speech
the majority does not agree with
it is about canceling 75
million trump voters playing to a
television audience that included the
former president watching in florida
the attorneys accused house impeachment
managers of selectively editing his past
comments but then they repeatedly played
selectively edited video democrats are
gonna fight like hell we
fight like hell i'm gonna fight like
hell i will fight like hell
falsely equating that those out of
context statements by democrats
make them just as guilty of using
aggressive speech to stir their
supporters
later mr trump's team was unable to
answer questions even from republican
senators
about when the former president learned
of the violence at the capitol
and his actions to stop it attorney
michael vanderveen
also dismissed questions about whether
he thought the former president won the
election
in my judgment it's irrelevant were mr
trump's words insightful to the point of
violence and riot that's the charge
that's the question and the answer is
no house democrats offered this those
are the questions
that we have as well and the reason this
question keeps coming up
is because the answer is nothing 17
republicans would need to join the 50
members of the democratic caucus to
convict mr trump
but few have signaled they will
the day's proceedings ended on a high
note as the senate unanimously agreed to
award the congressional gold medal one
of the nation's top civilian honors
to officer eugene goodman the capitol
police officer
who was seen on security footage
directing senators away from danger and
then directing a mob
away from the senate chamber he spent
most of this week watching the trial in
the chamber
as a new member of the senate
sergeant-at-arms office
jeff that was a great scene ed
we we also learned there was nearly
another shake-up in trump's defense team
before friday's presentation what can
you tell us about that that's right cbs
news has learned that the attorney david
shone
had threatened to quit over some
disagreements over trial strategy and
exactly
how to use that video that was featured
during friday's proceedings but the
president
former president convinced him to stay
on throughout the week it was clear that
the defense attorneys
for the president had struggled with
their presentation and
appeared to be at times recalibrating on
the fly another sign of how
tricky it is to be associated with and
to work and defend the former president
in this kind of a setting ed you
mentioned in your piece that few
republicans have signaled that they
would vote to convict
give us some sense of the overall senate
reaction right now
and sort of that political fallout if
republicans were to vote to convict
well look our polling this past week
showed that a majority of the country
believes the former president should be
convicted
by the senate but republicans look at
another number in our survey
73 percent of republicans polled say
that
supporting the former president is most
important and
a large percentage in the poll also say
that if the former president were to say
start his own political party
they'd go join it so there is real
real-time immediate short-term political
risk for some of these senators
who may be thinking it's worth
convicting but understand
that there's risk to themselves and to
the future of the republican party we do
expect at least five or six
republicans to join the democrats
whether we get more than that
again we won't know until a vote is held
and ed meanwhile the work in washington
continues what's the status on
president biden's 1.9 trillion dollar
plan
that stimulus it's an important question
michelle because as the senate this week
was focused on the impeachment trial of
the former president
over in the house they were working on
that on that coveted relief plan
that work will continue in the coming
week and it's expected democrats will
approve it
in the next two weeks it'll then head
over to the senate one key republican
susan collins of maine signaled this
week that she'd been in touch with the
president
about finding a way still to get
republicans to support the plan
they certainly uh let's say hope here at
the white house
republicans will sign on i i think that
was a very nice homage back there to the
hearts that were put out i believe
by the first lady for the president as a
surprise
uh yes and uh and and within eyesight of
of our cameras i'm just waiting to see
what they'll do with for christmas
uh whether they'll have any large lawn
ornaments here
don't steal anything yet all right and
thank you we appreciate the report take
care